you
[Music]
welcome to my talk thank you for for
joining me I'm going to talk a bit about
what I have been doing in mostly last
year first of all I started at our
studio a couple of months ago so that's
pretty great and I'm working on there
and so I am I am working on improving a
lot of stuff with the relation to this
but but this is kind of my last year
project it will probably get some more
support on but right now it's it's done
kind of stuff so what is what is did you
animate so did you animate is a package
I have wrote I it's kind of twofold
thing it's both a grammar of graphics
like a theoretical backbone of how to
describe animation and it's also an
implementation of sets theoretical
background so in the same sense that
there exists a grammar of graphics
theory and ggplot2 is just one of many
different implementation of this theory
what I wanted to do with GG animate was
also to kind of build a theoretical
backbone for how to address animation
and data visualization so so it's
twofold and on top of that it's an
extension to ggplot2 so it's not
something that exists on its own it is
something that you can apply to any of
your normal ggplot2 plots and make them
move magically lastly GG anime just not
what it was a year ago
so did you animate actually has a long
storied history starting with like years
ago drop David Robinson who sits down
there wrote GJ animate and he had some
other thoughts than me about how it
should look and he he made it and it was
fantastic and it got pretty popular and
at some point he made the big mistake of
asking me to take it over and I had some
other thoughts so so I rewrote it
completely which also means that if you
have codes from
year ago I I can assure you that it
won't run so I have broken a lot of
stuff but I I think I've done it for
four good reasons
furthermore David never made it to cran
with this package I did so it is now and
it is now on cran and and you can grab
it from there
and this of course is made with GG
animate so so you can use it to to do
both like serious animation if such a
thing exists but you can also use it to
to do whatever else you want to play
with so how do I use GG animate so I'm
not going to go too deep into the the
theoretical underpinnings of GG animate
in this talk this is more of how to get
you started doing your first animations
um but just to give you a bit of context
there are at least three quite important
parts of the grammar of animations
probably the most important part is its
what's called transition so what I've
called transitions which is you have
some data you want it to change over the
course of the animations then you need a
transition there is also something
called use which is you want your view
which is the y and x scale to change
during the animation how do you specify
that and then there's something called
shadows which is completely different
which is like you want the animation to
have some sort of memory you might be
like well which is which is fair enough
this is a one slide overview of the of
the grammar so if you want to understand
a bit more about the concepts of these
there is a web page Judy animate calm
and there's a getting started guide
which kind of holds your hand through
your first different types of animations
and and talks a bit about that further
there's I had a presentation at usual
last year which went into much more
detail about my my reasons for doing
these kind of things so do check them
out if you want to understand a bit more
about what I'm talking about right now
so diving headlong into the fur
example this is a data set that a lot of
people are familiar with and in the
context of animation it's also quite
important because ants rustling became
quite famous with presenting exactly
this this data set this is an overview
of how different countries have evolved
in terms of population in terms of life
expectancies in terms of GDP per capita
and and hence rustling really showed how
animation can be used as great great
storytelling devices in terms of
communicating this this data set so
let's play with it a bit this is a this
is a static version of course if I
wanted to make a static plot this is
probably not how I wanted to do it but
this is kind of our starting point for
our animation we make it as we would
with a GG plot there's a lot of code up
there but it shouldn't be that
problematic its standard ggplot code and
we wind up with this horribly over
plotted scatter plot so how do we make
this move well it's actually quite
simple here we we have we want to
animate it over year and year is a
continuous variable so we use the
transition time function and we give it
year and say well do something with this
and what we get is wait it's moving this
there's actually a lot of stuff that
happens behind the scene here because
what you're seeing is not only the the
underlying data but as you can see it's
moving quite smoothly even though the
data that doesn't support it
GJ animate will will interpolate your
data to ensure that that your your
animation is smooth and it will do it in
such a time such a way that if I asked
for like 10,000 frames for a four minute
animation of this it will create enough
frames to make it smooth so it's not
something that you do upfront you don't
have to worry about the length of your
animation when you're coding it it's
something that's done when it's rendered
so so the specification of the animation
is kind of unitless and in that sense so
that's it that's how you use GG animate
there's any questions there's of course
a lot more to it like for instance if
you want this kind of animation you you
don't really have a scale in the same
way that you have a scale for your
x-axis there a progress bar would be
some sort of scale that that allowed you
to see where you were in your animation
I don't have that yet I'm looking into
it but one thing you can do is that you
can change your your titles or your
labels on your plot and and one way you
can can do this is that I have added
support for for the glue package which
allows you to insert different variables
into your your different titles and
labels on your plot and the different
transitions gives you different
variables that you can you can input
depending on what kind of transitions
you have so here we have the frame time
so each frame will actually expose the
time that is this frame is meant to be
and we can see that it updates nicely
and this actually allows for quite a
powerful way of changing your labels
during flooding I would say that that's
the end of this animation but let's
let's try to play a little a little bit
with it I don't the following animations
probably won't be better but they will
be different we can add a view to it
like we talked about we wander we can
use a view to update the the extent of
the animation here we say we will use
view follow view follow will simply look
at the data that is in each frame and
and just kind of enclose that and I'm
setting fixed wide to say well don't
mess with the y-axis just update the
x-axis to fit the data in and we can see
that well it does that I would say that
these kind of changing changing scales
are used with care they should be used
with care they can be quite disorienting
I don't think that it adds anything
positive so this plot but just to kind
of show off the views we can also do
other stuff like the shadows shadows
were probably the the most huh part of
that the slide that you saw something
with memory and all that it's a it's a
kind of a wet concept but when you when
you see the result it kind of makes
sense
so here we we add something called a
shadow wake which is something that
allows you to trail the the old frames
in the in the current frame so so what
you see here is that that we add a kind
of a trail behind the behind the points
and this is what I mean with with memory
so so what you're seeing is the old data
from the from the previous frames
actually being shown in this in a
current frame now this looks super cutie
and not necessarily super or important
there is actually used for such a thing
as this I don't say that it's useful for
this it's just adds over plotting but
what these kind of trailers can show you
is both it can show you some kind of
momentum how fast are things moving in
which direction are they moving so they
can actually allow you to to better
position yourself and during the
animation just to show beat the dead
horse there's other types of shadows
here's something called shadow mark
which allows you to keep raw data points
in your animation as the animation
progresses and you can you can change
the aesthetics of that data point so as
you can potentially see you can see that
a lot of points are being left behind us
as these this animation evolves again
this is probably not the best use case
for it but but if you have fewer data
points it can actually allows you to to
remember where the different raw dates
are actually worse during the animation
okay new example this is some
temperature data that I that I fished in
don't look too much at that code is just
for reproducibility this is just
grabbing a lot of of temperature
measurements in Copenhagen and Austin to
kind of justify why I went here for
January and the static version is just
quite a similar line graph and as you
can see it's it should at least be quite
a bit warmer here so so I made the right
choice so how would I want to to animate
that well if I wanted to - like a pier
for one day for one day at a time you
might think well days are continuous as
well so
let's try a transition time again and
you will end up with this animation and
you might think of something is broken
this is an animation there's just
nothing in there
and and you you would probably be kind
of like what but then when you think
about it transition time will will cut
up your data into the different time
slips that you have and you have one
measurement per time and you're trying
to draw a line with one measurement
which results in no lines so of course
nothing gets drawn and then you might
think way there's a use case for shadows
because that gives you memory so will at
shadow mark which repeats the old raw
data there and we get this which again
like you might be at the point where you
say well this is really a one-trick pony
can't really do what I wanted to do and
the thing is that it's actually doing
what it should be doing what you might
fail to grasp with because it's a quite
complicated thing is that well shadows
don't really combine the old data with
the new data so it is cutting things up
but it's just again drawing a lot of one
point lines here it's doesn't the shadow
data never connects itself with the old
data for good reasons because it's not
what it's meant to do so what you really
want here is another transition because
this is a completely different way of
making animation and I have a transition
just for that which is the transition
rear wheel and what we see is it's
actually doing what we wanted it to do
and oh that's June 10 sorry
maybe my computer crashed I'll just try
again okay what this precision also
allows you to do is to add other things
on lines and and it will try to
interpret that in a nice sense so if you
add the same data just as Jim points you
will as you probably expect has have a
point that the kind of traces the the
frontier of the animation what you don't
usually have with Jim points is that you
I'm specifying a group aesthetic here
that's not something that you usually do
for points but the group aesthetic in
India animate has been kind of given an
additional purpose in in defining the
the permanence of objects across Freyja
frames so you need that to kind of say
well this point is the same and you need
to trace it over so what happens if it
has another really weird what happens if
you you give it a unique unique group
well then it doesn't really get combined
across the frames it will just kind of
appear there lastly we can do other
types of kinds of visualization here I
do a GM smooth what you if you need to
animate that you can no longer reference
the weekday because the statistics
transformations that you you've done
make the week they disappear at the
moment that you do think of the
animation but in the same way as you can
reference statistically computed values
during aesthetics you can also do that
in transition reveal and we will just
say wait until you have done the
statistics transformation and then grab
the x value that comes out of GM smooth
and we can again do this I'm running low
on time so I'll just jump onto a happy
little data set of earthquakes what this
has nothing to do with the quality of GJ
animate I must say that
this is purely quino's fault
so I've just made and made up a plot and
and again if you want to animate that we
can like make the bass appear one month
again this is so will and we do that
with transition States January February
and so on you could consider them as
continuous variables but but here in the
sense that they are ordered faxes so
we're using a discrete scale which is
transition States and we add shadow
Magus we've seen before because we want
the old the old month data to kind of
stay there and we can see what we get
what we expect is what we might think is
a bit truth is that they just kind of
pop out out of nowhere it's not nearly
as smooth that you as you might want to
have it and what we can do about this is
a new concept that I haven't really
talked about before something called
entering and exit modifications so here
we are adding something called into grow
and and this will simply just say when
something new pops up let it grow I'm
not going to sing anything now don't
worry so so you can you can actually
like you can add flourish like this and
it's actually it allows the the
animation to appear much more smoothly
and and do you animate comes with a with
a number of these different these
different entering and exiting sessions
or entering exit modifications and you
can you can combine them so you can
actually like integral and into fade and
it will do both of these at the same
time so you can do quite a lot with the
building stuff like so so I guess this
is the last line I made it in time
so there'll be time for questions while
Hadley melts away thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
[Music]
so I think we have time for one question
and then if you have more questions for
Thomas he's happy to stay here for the
rest of his life
precisely
hey great talk thank you how does Gigi
animate handle gaps in the data in all
of the examples that you had you had
uniform periods between data how does it
handle something that has whole isn't it
great question so I I didn't show all
the different transitions there's quite
a lot because there's quite a lot of
different ways to interpret data in a
time sense so with transition with
transition time you would it kind of
looks at the data as keyframes so so if
some days it disappear it will be
considered disappearing and and it will
be removed but sometimes you want it to
kind of just drift over to the next
position transition component this is
for when you have these kind of non
keyframe setups where each element moves
based on its own like time time points
so you can absolutely do that
just ensure
[Music]